this year the Academy presents a special
award for the first time and to make the
first presentation here is a First Lady
of Hollywood who is equally at home in
drama comedy and okhta to ravishing
Rosalind Russell
one of the cautions pursued by drama
students is makeup indeed in the theatre
the actor replies his own but in Motion
Pictures a very highly specialized
medium we who toiled as performers are
happily surrounded with a whole core of
wonderful makeup artists there are
highly skilled and dedicated and they
are really often the unsung heroes but
tonight we sing them all by honouring
one so the board of governors of the
Motion Picture Academy of Arts and
Sciences has voted to give an honorary
Oscar to a deer an old friend who has
made a science of the art of makeup and
an art of the sciences makeup this is
going to be given to him because he took
this face and he turned it into these
faces all for the MGM production seven
faces of dr. Lowe and now for this
outstanding achievement this wonderful
award goes to an equally wonderful man
mr. William couple
and I happen to know that this is Bill's
own faith my sincere thanks to the Board
of Governors of the Academy and to
metro-goldwyn-mayer and my wonderful
staff and makeup department from
hairdressing department and a very
special thanks to Tony Randall who
brought the seven phases of dr. Lao to
life and most of all to a great pal of
mine mr. George pal
you